North Korea
firing an
intercontinental ballistic missile
that flew for more than 70 minutes.
That is the longest missile
flight ever for North Korea.
Kim Jong un,
they say personally guided the test
firing of the missile.
That is according to North
Korean state media.
The launch coming just days
after Kim Jong un's sister
vowed retaliation over an alleged U.S.
spy plane.
Which they say flew over North
Korean territory.
Will Ripley is OUTFRONT
A menacing milestone for North Korea's
missile program.
Pyongyang's latest ICBM launch
breaking its own record
for the longest ever missile flight.
A staggering 74 minutes hurtling
high above the earth
at supersonic speed, hitting 6000
kilometers before splashing
down in the sea.
The massive missiles
potential striking range, the entire U.S.
mainland and most of the world.
Pyongyang's most provocative
launch in months,
coinciding with this NATO's
summit in Lithuania,
quickly condemned by Japan
as an unacceptable threat
to regional stability.
South Korea's
military ready to overwhelmingly respond.
The ICBM,
a crown jewel in leader
Kim Jong un's nuclear arsenal,
protecting the power, fortune
and future of the ruling Kim family.
His young daughter, Kim Ju
a often appearing alongside her dad,
barely ten years
old, the rising star of a state
propaganda campaign
carefully crafted by Kim's
younger sister,
the mastermind of the Kim family brand.
The leader's loyal confidante,
trusted adviser,
and perhaps the most powerful woman
in North Korea.
She is the number two war.
That is for sure.
But actually, she is very smart lady
and she actually knows
that her position is secure
only when her brother is secure
just five years ago.
Very few people knew of Kim Yo Jong.
She stepped on the South Korean soil,
the first member of North
Korea's ruling family to cross the DMZ.
She carried a message of peace
from Pyongyang,
North Korean athletes and cheer squads.
We got a warm
welcome at the 2018 Winter Olympics.
She rose to fame as a fixture
at her brother's side.
Standing silently behind Kim
as he met with former President Trump.
That brief
period of diplomacy
feels like a distant memory.
The silent sister, now
a loud voice of defiance,
issuing fiery statements on state media,
often laced with crude language.
This week,
she threatened to shoot down U.S.
spy planes
accusing them
without evidence of entering
North Korean territory.
Warning in case of repeated
illegal intrusions, the U.S.
forces will experience
a very critical flight.
Past actions proved she's not all talk.
In 2020
a dispute with South Korea
ended with a bang.
Kim ordered the demolition
of a joint liaison office at the border.
Turning diplomatic dreams
into a pile of rubble.
She blew up that building
because she was angry about activists
sending balloons with leaflets
that oppose the regime.
That was her response.
Let's blow up the building.
And she is the second
most powerful person
in this nation
that has a ever growing nuclear arsenal.
And yet she's
the one that says the US is hostile
and aggressive.
She called South Korea's
president a fool recently.
And now that the Washington declaration
will strengthen
the military alliance between the U.S.
and South Korea,
we can expect a lot more from her
Oh, all right.
Thank you very much, Will Ripley.